oh I'm so sorry
watch where you're going little [ __ ] who
gave you ownership of this sidewalk no
Jameson hey hey how are you I'm good uh
how are you good you should grab coffee
and catch up uh why not I mean I'm over
it but if you need need the coffee
forward the closure that yes
I'll text you cool so good seeing you
mm-hmm bye will Mike be joining us or
has he moved on to sleeping with someone
else who's just a friend
damn it that's what I show us sad hey
Jameson hey you're gonna have those
reports done by end of day yeah I'm just
waiting on the last one to come in great
I'm gonna go get some coffee I have to
bring the whole pot to get through this
meeting yeah or we could just take an
expresso shot every time somebody says
fiscal year
Oh Todd its James I see for once you
don't look like a cross between a
goodwill mannequin and underpaid
vice-principal I'd be surprised but I
saw you download a style up at lunch
yesterday excuse me
next time oh hey Jameson hey Kevin guy
in big plans this weekend huh no not
really probably just gonna catch up on
some sleep
yeah well that makes sense since you
broke a lot eh oh yeah this week is
really creamy where is that too sexual
whatever strip hey Kevin headed to work
yep
all right have a good shift Thanks oh
and I emptied the dishwasher again I'm
sorry I'm just really tired from having
to cover your half of the electric bill
again you know probably best you didn't
hear that
[Music]
Carl still Jameson looks like the style
app is down today oh you know I was
gonna shop a basic [ __ ] boutique like
you but they didn't have anything my
size it's okay honey you wouldn't be
able to afford it anyway
[Music]